today I'm going to build a private and
secure smart home from scratch then
stupidly give up my privacy by letting
gpt4 in the front door here's what
almost every day of my life looks like
wake up at 5am turn on my lights
microwave a breakfast Hot Pocket check
on the baby turn on computer and wait 10
minutes for Windows to update write some
code make a YouTube video microwave a
lean pocket open the door for friendly
strangers join a new religion dishes
it's a beautiful life but highly
inefficient every time I turn on a light
it takes 500 000 microseconds out of my
day over the course of a year that's
like two weeks spent just turning on
lights luckily there's a free and open
source tool called home assistant that
can automate and control all the
technology in our homes in today's video
we'll build a smart home from scratch
and look at all the crazy things people
do with home automation but most
importantly we'll keep all the data
private to your home network which means
hackers and feds can't spy on you then
we'll completely break that rule by
giving our data to open AI to integrate
it with chatgpt giving us a glimpse into
what a Next Generation smart home might
look like but first we've got a huge
giveaway thanks to our awesome spawn
monster Bridge they're a startup that's
building a protocol that enables iot
devices powered by bluetooth low energy
to Leverage The Cloud what's awesome
though is that these smart devices don't
need to be fitted with cellular or Wi-Fi
connectivity instead they use mobile
apps as an internet gateway to
effectively bridge data between the
internet and the iot device and that's
huge because it means you can now build
iot products without the need for
cellular or Wi-Fi on your Hardware I've
been playing around with it myself with
an esp32 microcontroller and now you can
too because bridge is shipping out
hundreds of these boards for free right
now once you have one you just installed
a firmware download the demo app and
then you can start securely storing
interactions like inputs from a sensor
on the back end Ledger as part of the
bridge protocol and if you manage to
build something cool you could even
connect it to your home assistant which
we're going to set up right now but
first what is home assistant exactly
it's a free and open source project
written in Python that allows you to
control all the technology in your home
locally where your privacy can be
protected it runs a UI on your local
network where you can manage all these
devices and automate them based on
different events that happen in the
world this can all be done without
writing any code or you can write your
own custom blueprints in yaml it has a
huge community and people do all kinds
of crazy stuff with it it can do simple
things like cook your hot pocket when
you wake up or turn your entire house
into a rave when the Sun goes down the
possibilities are endless so let's go
ahead and get it set up you'll first
need a dedicated server or machine to
host it it could be an old computer you
have laying around and home assistant
runs on Mac windows and Linux but I
think the ideal option is a Raspberry Pi
I'm going to be using a Raspberry Pi 4
which are very hard to come by as of
today but it works just as well on a pi
3. in addition to the pie itself you'll
want to make sure you have a good power
supply and ethernet cable and a Micro SD
card with at least 32 gigabytes but the
more memory you have the better
especially if you plan on storing video
data and then finally you'll need a way
to read an SD card like a USB MicroSD
reader and now we can move on to step 2
installing home assistant on the pi plug
your SD card into your primary computer
then download the Raspberry Pi imager
program this is an official Raspberry Pi
tool that'll help you download the right
operating system click on choose OS then
go to others specific purpose than home
automation then home assistant and then
you should see the distro for the
Raspberry Pi 4 or 3. go ahead and select
the one for your model then click on
choose storage and select your SD card
now click right and it will download
install and verify that operating system
on the SD card when that's done you can
pop it out and insert it into the pi and
now in step 3 we can take the pi connect
it to the power supply then use the
ethernet cable to connect it to your
Wi-Fi router it'll take a few minutes to
boot up but you should now be able to
access the home assistant website from
your local network and you'll also
likely want to install the home
assistant iOS or Android app to control
your house from your phone the first
time you access it it'll take you
through the onboarding process where you
create a username and password once
that's done it will take you to the
dashboard then from here you'll likely
want to go to the settings tab and then
link up any smart devices you have in
your home like Casa plugs Your Nest
Thermostat zigbee switches roombas
dishwashers cameras and so on once you
have a device connected you can then
control it manually some devices are
simple like a smart plug you can just
turn on and off with a switch but other
devices are are more complex like my
smartphone has all kinds of different
sensors and I can access them to do
something in my home when something
changes on my phone like maybe when the
battery level gets low I trigger a shock
collar to remind myself to plug it back
in home assistant is all about doing
automations like this if we go to the
automations tab the first thing you'll
need to automate something is a trigger
this could be a certain time on the
calendar it could be an event like when
a button is clicked somewhere it could
be a message passed from some other
device using mqtt it could be a web Hook
from some external service and a variety
of other patterns from there you can
optionally add conditions to make sure
the trigger is only activated if a
certain condition is met like maybe you
don't want to run any alarms if it's the
middle of the night and then finally an
action is the thing that should happen
when the trigger occurs most often this
will be something on a device like maybe
you want to switch a plug on or off or
you might want to send a push
notification to your phone that's pretty
cool but sometimes you might have a lot
of actions that you want triggered all
at once like in my case I don't want my
kids getting out of bed before 7am so I
programmed A system that lets them know
when it its time at exactly 7 AM their
light bulbs turned green their speaker
plays eye of the tiger the printer
prints them a list of chores kitchen
starts making breakfast and the Roomba
follows them around to clean up any
messes and pretty soon I'll be able to
hook up a full self-driving Tesla to it
to automatically drive them to school to
organize that more efficiently I created
a scene a scene allows you to organize
the state of multiple devices in a
single place that means you can
reactivate that scene from multiple
triggers or do it manually with a single
click but sometimes a scene is not
enough with scripts you can create an
entire sequence of events occasionally I
want my house to go into party mode
where the lights fade in and Fade Out
and Flash different colors but to make
that happen we need to code in some
delays and other patterns to synchronize
all the lights we can implement this
logic entirely from the home assistant
UI or if you're more comfortable with
code everything can be represented in
yaml but what's really awesome about the
code is that it can be shared with other
people there are all kinds of Home
assistant blueprints that give you
pre-configured functionality so you
don't have to do all this stuff manually
like you just import a blueprint to
manage your solar panels make some minor
changes and your done there's so much
cool stuff to do here and I could go on
and on but now I want to give up my home
privacy to my AI overlords at openai if
you go to the Integrations tab you'll
find all kinds of different services and
apis that you can integrate into your
workflow one of which is an open AI
integration giving us access to gpt4 it
simply takes our API key and then
formats a prompt with the current data
or state of our smart home from there on
the home assistant dashboard you'll
notice a chat icon that allows us to
access chatgpt within the context of our
own home we can ask it questions about
the current state of the home but
currently it can't take control over the
home although I think you can see where
this is going in the near future Dean
Koontz an author who wrote about the
Wuhan 400 virus in the 80s also wrote a
book called demon seed in 1977 that
describes a hyper-intelligent smart home
that locks the lady inside and has her
Barrett's child so you might want to be
a little extra cautious when inviting
gpt4 into your smart home thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one